françois rebsamen l invité de preuves
par 3 ce soir bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous maire de dijon
ancien ministre du travail dans les
premiers gouvernements de manuel valls
et à ce titre évidemment votre avis sur
la loi travail nous intéresse
particulièrement
de même que votre proximité historique
avec françois hollande on y reviendra
dans cette émission vous connaissez bien
le principe de cette émission divisé en
trois parties et il nous faudra répondre
à trois questions principales la
première question peut-on encore sauver
la loi travail alors que le premier
ministre poursuit jusqu'à demain ces
consultations auprès des partenaires
sociaux est alors surtout que nous
sommes à la veille de la manifestation
premières manifestations contre ce
projet de loi
deuxième partie de cette émission avec
notre partenaire l' agence france-presse
stéphanie le rouge viendra vous demander
si le parti socialiste peut mourir tant
le parti apparaît divisée à la fois sur
la loi travail mais également sur la
déchéance de nationalité de nationalité
pardon également sur la primaire et puis
enfin troisième partie de cette émission
avec notre journaliste michaël szames
est ce si vous étiez encore
parlementaire encore sénateur françois
rebsamen est ce que vous vous feriez la
déchéance de nationalité
la révision constitue constitutionnel
sera effectivement examinée la semaine
prochaine par le sénat le premier
ministre était auditionné ce matin par
la commission des lois et on a vu qu'on
était encore loin d'une position
convergente avec l'assemblée nationale
alors première partie de cette émission
françois rebsamen première question
peut-on encore sauver la loi travail
votre avis bien sûr non seulement la
sauver mais mieux la présenter
l'expliquer et tenir compte des
remarques des propositions d'amendements
et modifications qui ont été fait ou qui
vont être faits par les syndicats
réformistes dont combien ce sera un
recul pourquoi un recul la négociation
qui s'ouvre et qui est celle ouverte
avec les syndicats réformistes elle est
indispensable elle est avec d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
et patronales donc c'est bien de les
écouter c'est bien de les entendre
et d'avancer des arguments d'entendre
des arguments contre et je pense qu'il y
aura des modifications qui seront
apportées à cette loi la partie moi-même
lamarti pourtant semble mal engagée non
non je ne le crois pas moi même j'avais
émis quelques réserves sur revenir sur
deux fois d'abord sur sur la
présentation qui avait pas été très à
droite et qui faisait peser a priori une
suspicion vous savez c'est dans ce pays
c'est comme ça une suspicion de dérive
droitière du texte présenté pourquoi
parce que je crois qu'il avait été dit
que le gouvernement prendrait ses
responsabilités si nécessaire et donc 49
3 avait été évoquée voilà mais je crois
qu'il avait été formulée comme je lé
indiqué mais la vérité
première remarque selon vous c'est le
défaut le manque de pédagogie autour du
texte
oui défauts réels de communication oui
mais je crois que ce texte sorti alors
même qu'il était envoyé au conseil
d'état qui n'est pas encore été présenté
au conseil des ministres
et donc du coup mais il a fallu remettre
l'ouvragé sur le métier et recommencer
commencer rien cette erreur de
communication
enfin je ne sais pas je ne sais pas moi
j'ai la ville de foot non je crois qu'il
ya eu
le texte a été envoyé au haut conseil
d'état vous savez avant on vérifie vous
le savez bien
on vérifie que les articles qui sont
envoyées sont conformes au droit et on
prend en compte les remarques du conseil
d'état l'ars avait même pas le texte est
sorti comme ça
brut de décoffrage je sais pas comment
ça a pu se faire et donc à partir de là
il faut reprendre le bâton d'explication
de pèlerin pour expliquer les choses
dire que ce texte est bien c'est pas
c'est parce qu'on croit c'est pas une
dérive c'est pas le rejeter dans l'art
du travail normalement la loi larcher
impose la consultation des partenaires
soit il ya eu ces consultations
bilatérales qui ont été menées pas
surtout les parts mirex tamar myriam el
khomri alors on me dit qu'il ya eu
quelques rajouts de dernière minute la
concertation à l'élan
alors au vu des premières consultations
du premier ministre avec les partenaires
sociaux
cette semaine on constate quand même
encore de profonds désaccords notamment
avec la cfdt
je vous propose françois rebsamen
d'écouté de laurent berger le secrétaire
général de la cfdt
nous avons été écoutés il nous a été dit
que la porte était ouverte au dialogue
que des choses pouvaient évoluer qu'il y
avait des espaces et nous a pas été
donné de réponse parce que les les
auditions entre guillemets ne sont pas
ne sont pas terminées nous avons redit
notre détermination à agir contre les
mesures que nous ne voulons pas voir
figurer dans ce texte et nous avons
redit que s'il n'y avait pas d'évolution
la cfdt serait en capacité de se
mobiliser pas l'air très conciliant
quand même encore laurent berger
françois rebsamen qu'il connaissait bien
il attend il attend effectivement de les
avancer sur des points que je connais et
notamment le barème des indemnités près
de mal le barème des indemnités
prud'homale et puis la définition des
licenciements économiques je crois que
ce sont deux points qui sont
essentielles aujourd'hui dans le débat
alors qu'elle avançait pas si vous voyez
est ce que par exemple sur l'aim sur le
barème des indemnités aux prud'hommes
est ce qu'on peut proposer par exemple
n'ont pas un plafond mais un plancher
d'indemnisation exosun aucune piste de
réflexion je pense que je pense qu'il
avait été laissé une marge de
négociation comme toujours aux
parlementaires parce que finalement ce
texte sortant du conseil d'état envoyés
présenté au conseil des ministres va
être mis entre les mains des
parlementaires la commission des
affaires sociales de l'assemblée pour
commencer va dire peut-être le plafond
qui est mis et insuffisant quand on
regarde par rapport à l'allemagne par
exemple je crois qu'après 20 ans de
travail c'est 24 mois en allemagne ces
quinze mois avec est proposé donc on
peut corriger cela j'indique quand même
que cette barémisation était déjà dans
la loi dans la loi macron moi j'étais
favorable mais ça avait été essentielle
mais oui pour pour d'autres raisons mais
j'y étais favorable si vous me permettez
je veux dire pourquoi je suis favorable
à une barémisation qui peut être
indicative elle n'est peut-être pas
obligatoire elle peut être indicative
pourquoi je suis favorable parce qu'avec
ma collègue christiane taubira on a fait
le tour des prud'hommes et il ya des
situations très différentes d'après
demain un autre et vous avez des
endroits où les salariés peuvent
attendre très longtemps j'ai entendu que
la moyenne était de 18 mois sûrement pas
de la région parisienne puisque il ya
encore un cas de septembre qui n'est pas
traitée entre une inégalité territoriale
un manque d'uniformité ou ou
d'uniformisation de la jurisprudence
donc ils tiller un barème de référence
je pense que c'est une bonne chose
voilà le jus exercèrent le mercure serre
selon vous ce serait je pense qu'il
faudrait faire comme comme en allemagne
en allemagne ouais
les patrons sont pas aussi forcément
satisfait par ce projet de loi notamment
la cgpme qui représente les tpe les pme
je vous propose d'écouter françois
asselin et puis on réagit ensuite nous
avons besoin de souplesse nous avons
besoin d'être rassurés nous avons besoin
qu'en cas malheureusement de
retournements de conjoncture et bien on
puisse adapter l'entreprise à son
environnement et nous constatons avec
beaucoup de regret qu autour de
certaines annonces qui sont dans ce
texte certains articles
eh bien il ya une totale de
désinformation qui a pris une ampleur
phénoménale
ce qu'on veut tout simplement c'est que
on sache lorsqu'il faut réduire la
voilure et bien où chacun met les pieds
que ça soit du côté du salarié comme du
côté de l'employeur surtout quand c'est
une petite entreprise qui souvent est
très fragile n'a pas les capacités
financières d'un d'un grand groupe
alors françois asselin fait allusion à
l'assouplissement du licenciement
économique est ce qu'il faudrait selon
vous dans ce texte différencier le cas
des tpe et des pme des grands groupes
oui vous savez quand on fait des
différences de ce genre on peut être
sanctionnée par le conseil
constitutionnel donc il ya à prendre
avec on est tous précaution non mais il
ya des dispositifs qui renvoie des
accords d'entreprises de petite
entreprise d'ailleurs dans le dans le
texte qui donne plus de place aux
accords d'entreprise et faut rappeler
quand même qu' il y à chaque année 36
milles accord d'entreprise qui sont
signés y compris d'ailleurs une majorité
par la cgt au niveau local donc le fait
qu'il y ait des accords d'entreprise
correspond je crois
à l'esprit de ce que demande de monsieur
à cela ce qui est vrai il faut donner de
la souplesse un peu plus de souplesse
aux entreprises vers en même temps il
faut pas retirer des droits aux salariés
ça c'est pas possible et donc on a
affaire cet équilibre je pense qu'il
faut revoir les conditions de définition
des licenciements économiques
quelles seraient vos propositions à vous
et bien d'allonger déjà les durées de
prise en compte parce que je pense que
quatre mois c'est beaucoup trop court 4
trimestre pendant que c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup trop long pour débourser
le quoi le kersa à 5 par exemple
non je pense que celle des ter d'ici ce
même je pense qu'il faut il faut revoir
ça on ne peut pas avoir de doute sur
l'interprétation sur les causes qui
amène à des licenciements économiques
donc cette redéfinition et à travailler
je pense que c'est ce qu'ils font avec
les syndicats réformistes nab selon vous
on peut encore trouver un compromis sur
ces deux points qui sont les deux points
qu'il fonde plus débat sur ce projet de
loi il y a le séminaire organisé ce soir
avec les partis parlementaires
socialistes
vous pensez que manuel valls peut encore
convaincre une partie de ses troupes
très hostile quand même encore au
premier loi oui mais je crois que ces
deux points sont deux points essentiels
et que les parlementaires socialistes en
sont conscients les présidents de
groupes avec lesquels j'ai pu
m'entretenir en sont conscients et si
j'ai bien entendu hier au bureau
national
il y avait beaucoup d'expressions en ce
sens au bureau national du parti
socialiste
tout à fait c'est donc qu'on a on à la
nécessité de bouche il faut bouger il
faut entendre et il faut pas se braquer
et dire qu'on est droit dans ses bottes
non la négociation la concertation a
lieu en ce moment
alors justement le bureau national du
parti socialiste et hier soir et on a pu
entendre la lourde charge à nouveau de
martine aubry contre ce projet de loi je
vous propose de réentendre martine aubry
et on discute après j'ai essayé
d'expliquer myriam el khomri que la
réforme du code du travail quelle
qu'elle prévoyait ni ne réforme ni qui
améliorent la compétitivité de
l'entreprise qui accroît la protection
des salariés
elle est extrêmement dangereuse
notamment sur le droit de licencier
non elle est dangereuse quand on
substitue des accords d'entreprise à des
accords de branche
mettant le paquet sur la formation sur
la recherche sur l'innovation
il faut que les salariés se sentent bien
aussi dans l'entreprise si on souhaite
effectivement ce qu'ils y soient attaque
chez qu'ils améliorent encore leur leur
compétitivité cette loi c'est donc une
régulation comme semble entendre en
train de dire les modifications
apportées moi je note que martine aubry
n'a pas demandé le rendu du texte y hier
mais des améliorations à apporter
et donc il faut apporter ces
améliorations j'ai donné deux exemples
mais je pense que on peut faire plus de
place c'est ce que souhaite la cfdt est
la raison aux accords d'entreprise je le
redis et donc il ya une norme on
respecte les normes
l'argumentaire comme quoi il y aura un
renversement de la hiérarchie des normes
faut pas exagérer
la loi reste la loi les accords
interprofessionnels aussi les accords de
branche aussi mais il peut y avoir des
accords d'entreprise et il peut y avoir
des référendum des salariés qui donnent
leur position
mais à entendre martine aubry on a
l'impression qu'on n'est plus tellement
dans la dimension technique mais dans
l'arrière pensée politique
elle est peut-être dans l'affectif oui
dans l'affectif vous trouvez-vous lui
dans sa relation à sa relation avec
myriam el khomri c'est ça justement
myriam el khomri quel regard vous portez
sur celle qui vous a succédé à ce
ministère c'est très difficile de parler
de quelqu'un qui vous a succédé je me
suis abstenu de le faire j'ai parlé de
mairie la même éthique ge ne l'ait pas
fait nous la marianne dit du bien d'elle
d'ailleurs dans la pqr encore ce
week-end c'est une c'est une femme
courageuse qui travaillent c'est une
belle personne
les épaules assez larges pour porter un
tel projet de loi dans ce contexte
politique le porte puis l épauler pour
le porter et manuel valls
c'est ce qui joue son autorité sam étape
sur ce projet de loi manuel valls et
c'est une c'est un moment important pour
lui il en est il en est conscient je
crois et donc il est
je trouve depuis quelques jours ouverts
à la négociation rencontre savait il a
une histoire qui est un peu commune avec
la cfdt il a toujours été proche des
syndicats réformistes et donc moi je ne
doute pas qu'il va les entendre
cambier qui joue un moment important
penser à quoi précis je pense nous
allons le passé on ne sait pas ce qui va
se passer demain on voit qu'il y a
heureusement maintenant des camps
économistes qui à nouveau prennent la
parole pour dire ce texte c'est pas l'un
famille qu on croit entendre tira le
désir des gens oui oui à me filer pas
lyon ce matin
donc voilà c'est des économistes qui
sont des les gens tout à fait connu et
reconnu
et si elle était ma surprise c'est quand
même que des gens qui ne connaissaient
pas le texte encore au départ est tout
de suite crier au loup
ah oui vous pensez à qui a personne à
personne
enfin une certaine tribune qui a été
publiée par exemple non parce que je
pense quand même qu'il se sont
renseignés mais je pense que c'est parti
très vite j'ai beaucoup de gens ont dit
de venir que le gouvernement a perdu la
bataille de la communication attend je
pense que je pense que la communication
était gelée dit mal engagée et que c'est
une des raison première de difficultés
que rencontre ce texte laissait penser
je voudrais dire une fois de laisser
penser que ce texte ne pourrait passer
entre guillemets qu'avec le 49-3 parce
que c'est ça que les gens ont compris ça
faisait peser sur ce test d'une certaine
suspicion dans la communication est mal
engagée ce que c'est rattrapable
oui se rattrapa par la concertation se
rattrapa par les gouttes et se rattrapa
par des modifications
malgré la mobilisation de demain les
manifs de la grève voire faux faux pas à
ça va être déterminé à tout mélanger
vous le savez non les quinze jours qui
viennent nous voir si on avance je pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait des avancées
significatives et que dans les
propositions des syndicats réformistes
soient prises en compte pourquoi
françois rebsamen pas parce qu'on a fait
déjà beaucoup de choses on a fait
beaucoup de choses et moi ce que je
constate c'est que malheureusement on ne
s'est jamais arrêtée pour dire ce qu'on
fait et ça c'est à des reproches majeurs
que je fais à l'histoire de ce
quinquennat c'est ne jamais avoir
valorisé ce qui avait été
dit de ne pas avoir dès le départ on
s'était un peu péché originel les
suppléments d'expression de ce
quinquennat ne pas avoir dit quelle
était la situation de ne pas avoir d
qu'est ce qu'on allait faire d'avoir eu
peut-être une vision un peu optimiste
des choses il faut le faut le
reconnaître
françois hollande face à commenter les
critiques de france politique non non je
je je
la situation n'est pas facile
elle n'était pas facile quand on est
arrivé tout de suite il ya eu délit des
plans de licenciements qui avait été
repoussée je peux penser à peugeot aps
un mois les reçus ici en tant que
président de groupe et patron du groupe
uni il s'en sort maintenant il a fallu
quatre ans pour que le groupe ressort
des bénéfices étaient très importants
donc voila et et puis il ya des choses
de faites des avancées ce jeu les dix la
bouche du réel c'est à dire celles qui
gouvernent en ce moment elle a créé des
nouveaux droits et mais simplement elle
les a pas meilleure valeur encore la
prime d'activité l'autre jour je
regardais on croirait que c'est là la
caf qui distribue ça comme ça par
décision de la caf très bien la caisse
d'allocations familiales fait très
belles choses mais c'est une décision
qui était d'ailleurs norma loy et qui a
été mise en oeuvre au 1er janvier
on peut parler d des retraites après les
carrières longues
on peut parler aussi du droit à la
formation personne n'a parlé vraiment de
ce droit à la formation
et puis du compte personnel d'activité
qui est une grande avancée qui est dans
le texte et qui devrait encore renforcer
donc je comprends la question est ce que
c'est un peu la faute quand même de
françois hollande qui n'a pas su mettre
en valeur ce bilan là qu'il abat
supporter peut-être on n'a pas su aussi
l'expliquer peut-être le parc on a
besoin dit qu'il manquait toujours une
ligne économique socialiste
n'at-il pas non plus fait le travail
d'explication qui était nécessaire
peut-être n'at-on pas pris le temps je
me mets dedans n'at-on pas pris le temps
de faire la pause de l'explication
donc on enchaîne les réformes les unes
après les autres
mais si on s'arrête pas un moment pour
dire voilà ce qui a été fait mais les
français ils ne sachent pas ils le
connaissent ils le savent pas ça leur
donne l'impression que tout n'a pas été
tenté contre le chômage
oui même si je le pense j'avais dit que
l'année 2015 serait meilleure que
l'année 2014 ouzou rappelait il y a
aujourd'hui au sens du bit est moins de
3 millions de chômeurs dans en france
voilà au sens du bit millions
deux millions huit cent soixante mille
selon les chiffres du pib mais combien
de chômeurs en plus d'être les dvg canal
françois hollande
si on prend les chiffres du bit et on
n'arrive pas vous savez vous permettez
de minutes d'explications il ya il ya
trois ans une minute il ya trois ans les
chiffres de pôle emploi et les chiffres
du pib du bureau international du
travail était identique à 100 milles
près il y avait 2 millions 900 mille je
me ressens c'est parler d'eux
aujourd'hui il y en a 2 millions 900
mille recensés par le véhicule
trois millions cinq cent mille recensés
par pôle emploi cherchez l'erreur
votre explication à vous donc mon
explication c'est que pôle emploi n'est
pas un outil statistique très bien et
bien on travaillera sur pôle emploi
alors sans cette semaine on va parler
fait à la deuxième partie de cette
émission avec un parti socialiste de
plus en plus divisés des ambitions qui
s'expriment aussi de plus en plus
ouvertement je pense par exemple
dernièrement à emmanuel macron une
primaire à gauche qui se dessine
on va aborder tout de suite ces
questions avec stéphanie le rouge
journalistes dans notre partenaire l'
agence france-presse
autour de cette question le ps peut-il
mourir mais avant d'accueillir se manie
le rouge que pèse exactement manuel
valls au sein du parti socialiste
alors selon la députée karine berger qui
était l'invité ce matin de notre
matinale
et bien il ne pèse pas plus que son
score de la primaire en 2011 on
l'écoutant à gauche de manuel valls hier
soir au bureau national c'était moins de
5% du bureau national donc s'il ya
irréconciliables it2
de gauche y en a une qui fait 5 % et
l'autre qui fait 95%
donc non moi je ne crois pas la fracture
irrémédiable de la gauche pense que le
parti socialiste est l'endroit où les de
gauche historique en tout cas ont
toujours cohabité mais qu' il faut pas
pousser le bouchon trop loin et que il y
à un certain nombre de positions qui ne
sont plus des positions de gauche quand
on donne un permis licencié à des
multinationales dans un texte de loi on
est on est en train de sortir du champ
de la gauche bonsoir stéphane est alors
le parti socialiste y mourir votre c'est
votre question à françois rebsamen
oui bonsoir monsieur rebsamen on a
commencé à l'évoquer tout à l'heure
martine aubry a publié il ya moins de 15
jours une tribune au vitriol est
désormais les les opposants à la
politique du gouvernement sont
majoritaires au bureau national du ps
est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya un
risque de scission d'explosion de ce
parti comme on a pu l'entendre je me
suis posé la question et j'ai d'ailleurs
fait une tribune sur ce sujet je pense
qu'il ya effectivement mais c'est pas
nouveau dans l'histoire du parti
socialiste il y a de gauche y en a une
qui est plutôt j'allais dire sociale
libérale et puis une autre qui est
plutôt la gauche traditionnelle que l'on
connaît du parti socialiste il ya un axe
central qui a toujours permis de
réconcilier ces deux gauches pour faire
ce qu'on appelle la synthèse entre les
deux est-ce que l'écart c'est le sens de
votre question aujourd'hui est telle que
ces deux gauches sont irréconciliables
je ne le crois pas je ne le crois pas et
j'ai eu le sentiment hier
bien sûr si je mets à part quelqu'un qui
est peut-être un peu spécifique dans le
parti socialiste comme gérard filoche
mais si on met à part gérard filoche et
bien j'ai eu l'impression que tout le
monde était pour avancer pour qu' il n'y
ait pas non pas un retrait du texte mais
une amélioration du test nous parlons du
texte sur le travail et donc je pense
que c'est de gauche ne sont pas
irréconciliables et moi je souhaite vous
je sois monsieur le premier ministre
manuel valls a dit
lui a parlé de deux gauches
irréconciliables justement donc vous
inscrivez en faut il penser de la pensée
si tout est là la gauche de jean luc
mélenchon ou effectivement la rupture là
et consommer d'ailleurs on a mené
différence aujourd'hui entre jean luc
mélenchon et les frondeurs du parti
social il a une grande différence c'est
que ces gens semblent au bureau national
du parti socialiste en échange on a des
débats on avance ensemble et il ya des
interventions qui sont faites par
certains frondeurs qui sont de qualité
qui permettent d'améliorer encore entre
manuel valls et les frondeurs mais il ya
le débat il ya l'amélioration il s'est
dit décidée de linguee mais c'est ce
sont deux lignes qui sont différentes
mais qui cohabitent au sein du parti
socialiste et comptent souvent cohabiter
on pourrait dire rocard
je cherche en quarts chevénement et avec
mitterrand qui faisait là c'est ce que
manuel valls joue pas un peu sa propre
partition malgré tout face à hollande
qui doit rassembler la gauche le plus
possible manuel valls poursuit son
sillon de réformistes et peut-être au
risque de se curer de thune party la
gauche oui cette scène un réformiste
mais moi je pense que c'est un
réformiste de gauche et donc il doit
rester un réformiste de gauche et le
réformisme de gauche c'est une part
essentielle du parti socialiste vous
voyez pas une feuille de papier entre
pas dit ça il ya des différences il y a
des 10 il ya des divergences il ya des
différences je pense qu'elles ne sont
pas irréconciliables elles tiennent à
quoi elles tiennent peut-être à des des
postures personnel une analyse
différente de la société je pense que le
premier ministre est aujourd'hui
convaincu que la société attend de
l'autorité je crois qu'il lacarne bien
et je pense que une autre partie delà de
la gauche du parti socialiste
à l'intérieur du parti socialiste pense
que c'est la question sociale qui est
primordial et donc moi je pense que ce
n'est pas contradictoire je dois le dire
ici il faut qu'il y ait de l'autorité
parce qu'il faut donner de la protéger
et assurer la sécurité la sûreté nos nos
concitoyens sur tout
période troublée comme elles sont
aujourd'hui et puis en même temps alors
ça c'est peut-être un peu ma
particularité
je pense qu'il faut prendre en compte la
question sociale la question sociale
le modèle social français c'est quelque
chose dont on doit se préoccuper je suis
très heureux de voir que manuel valls
mène aujourd'hui les consultations les
concertations et les négociations j'en
ai mené avec lui d'ailleurs quand
j'étais d'ailleurs le texte que j'ai
plaisanté il a été adopté par la gauche
et il n'a pas été adopté par le 49-3
alors justement sur ce crime à gauche et
sur le couple exécutif je vous propose
d'écouter le sénateur socialiste
le cameroun a un proche de manuel valls
à voilà simplement un président un
premier ministre qui depuis le début de
ce quinquennat on vit la russie du pis
on n'est pas en train de parler deux
destins personnels ou de carrière
personnelle on voit bien que c'est un
jeu collectif qui de nous emmener vers
l'élection présidentielle qui va être
difficile il faut le reconnaître parce
qu'il ya de fortes interrogations chez
nos concitoyens est en tous les cas on
aura besoin des maires des
parlementaires pour qu'ils soient des
relais oui vous pensez qu'il n'y a pas
de divergence entre françois hollande et
manuel valls comme l'a dit monsieur
carvena pense que les arbitrages sont
rendus en commun oui oui je le pense
président de la république est dans son
rôle pour un ministre aussi non je pense
que les choses se font en commun
rien de ce qui se fait dans ce pays née
à l'étranger au président de la
république en matière de décision donc
voilà après le le premier ministre il a
aussi son tempérament il met les choses
en ordre
à sa manière donc ça c'est sûr il ya des
différences de tempérament tandis que
manuel valls a tendance à hystériser le
le débat ce qui n'est pas forcément la
meilleure chose dans la perspective de
2017 du rassemblement de la gauche
est-ce que vous pensez que françois
hollande sera en mesure de rassembler sa
gauche pour être candidat en 2017 je le
souhaite je l'espère malgré ce qu'il
soit fâché d'une part avec la gauche
sociétale sur la déchéance et maintenant
avec la gauche sociale autour du texte
c'est françois hollande c'est le
président de la république sortant
c'est le point d'équilibré de la gauche
je le pense je pense que ce sera ce
serait c'est lui qui prendra cette
décision bien sûr le meilleur candidat
pour nous celui qui est capable de
rassembler voilà donc le parti
socialiste allemand est condamné à la
synthèse hollande est oui c'est vous
savez elle je peux pas parler de
m'interroger sur le parti socialiste
veut bien répondre il
effectivement il peut il peut mourir le
parti socialiste effectivement il peut
exploser le parti socialiste peut y
avoir des fractures et des médias il ya
déjà eu quelques départs ça arrivait
dans son histoire
la question qu'on se pose souvent parti
socialiste c'est est ce que le cycle
d'epinay est terminée et donc à chaque
fois qu'il ya un problème la question
revient sur la table il y en a qui
brandit sa et qui dit le cycle d'epinay
terminait plus les parties ça ça me
laure ça se transforme ça se régénère on
le voit à droite aussi à gauche c'est
pareil
par contre je suis sûr d'une chose c'est
que la gauche elle ne mourra pas et ceux
qui de temps en temps s'exprimant devant
la gauche peut mourir non la gauche le
parti
c'est une erreur le parti socialiste
louis le mouël
le premier secrétaire jean christophe
cambadélis avait lancé cette idée
d'alliance populaire justement pour
renouveler le parti ça a pas l'air de
très bien fonctionner est-ce que la
primaire pour la présidentielle ça
pourrait être un autre moyen de faire ce
que les gauches parle à nouveau de
grandes maisons causant des jean
christophe cambadélis assez dubitatif
non je suis dubitatif parce que in fine
il faut que tout le monde soit soit
d'accord pour participer à cela
donc il faut donc s'il ya une primaire
bon il faut qu'à la sortie de la
primaire il ya un seul candidat ce
serait d'ailleurs une bonne chose
après est ce que le président de la
république s'il est candidat on met
beaucoup de si l'un est ce qu'il a envie
de se plier à cette primaire je n'en
sais rien ça peut être une bonne
occasion s'il y a à la sortie qu'un seul
candidat
mais c'est pas facile de faire une
primaire en étant président de la
république vous en conviendrez surtout
une situation difficile qu'on connaît
qu'il connaît le pays aujourd'hui
c'est pourtant ce que certains
souhaitent notamment ici au sénat je
vous propose d'écouter marie noëlle
lienemann la sénatrice elle voudrait une
primaire qui irait jusqu'à françois
hollande
en l'écoutant il vous demande du
primaire pourquoi parce qu'il faut qu'au
moment des primaires s'incarne des
personnes et des propositions peut pas
séparer l'un et l'autre et il a les
électeurs qui seront primaire pourront
choisir moi j'ai caché à personne que
j'étais prête à être candidate et que je
serai candidate si à des primaires mais
pour moi la priorité c'est un qui lie à
déprimer 2
vous savez je me méfie de ces
incarnations personnel la vème
république nous fait croire cela quel
est le camp aujourd'hui qui à l'homme
providentiel personnes voient la marina
l'ennemane qui était interrogé au salon
de l'agriculture c'est pour ça qu'on
entend un petit coq
au début la compagnie une bonne partie
du ps les frondeurs la motion b de
karine berger se sont prononcés pour la
primaire mais mon chinois au sujet d'une
primaire je pense une primaire de de
toute la gauche j'ai repris la formule
donc des macros et mélenchon oui je
pense que c'était une bonne idée
il faut que tout le monde ait la volonté
quand on fait une primaire de débattre
et d'accepter le résultat de cette
primaire sans passer par la case
hollande
si le président est candidat il dira
s'il se plie ou pas à la primaire la
primaire c'est aussi l'occasion de
d'affronter ou de confronter plus
exactement des lignes politiques et
c'est pour ça que marie noëlle lienemann
les et cela elles représentent une
partie de l'histoire du parti des
socialistes
est-ce que la participation de monsieur
mélenchon est indispensable parce que on
a pu avoir l'impression que
en faire un préalable était une manière
de dire non à la primaire avant que fait
donc est ce que vous vous dites oui
pourquoi pas une primaire y compris sans
mélanger confessant mélenchon je vous
dis comprises sans mélenchon mais c'est
vrai que l'idée était quand même d'avoir
un résultat qui qui couvrent tout le
champ de la gauche et de la gauche de la
gauche mais avec mélenchon c'est
extrêmement compliqué vous le savez
peut-être un proche depuis longtemps de
françois hollande françois rebsamen est
ce que vous continuez à le voir
régulièrement
beaucoup s'interrogent dans son
entourage je le vois veut et ce qu'il
pourrait être candidat en 2017
je me tiens on n'a pas parlé pour lui il
en parle à personne non je ne crois pas
en tous les cas ils ne peuvent pas moins
pas moi je le vois quand je demande à le
voir sans trop de difficulté mais de
cela nous n'avons pas encore parlé
donc on sent beaucoup d'interrogations
dans son entourage certains semble un
petit peu perdues sur sa stratégie est
ce que c'est également votre cas non moi
je pense que le moment venu fera
connaître son choix
toute façon il peut pas le faire
maintenant puisqu'il a pris moi je crois
à la parole présidentielle
il a dit que sa candidature était liée à
la version de la courbe du chômage et
donc vraiment a nié par sa chute je le
crois alors après qu'elle ait lequel est
l'outil de référence 1 c'est pour ça que
j'ai parlé d'humilité vous l'aviez bien
contré à l'air plus que des statistiques
de pôle emploi
mais de toute façon à terme si le
chômage diminue ça se verra aussi dans
les statistiques de pôle emploi
et jusqu'à quand peut-il attendre avant
de se déclarer on a pu entendre qu' il
pourrait
faire savoir qui n'est pas candidat s'il
ne l'est pas en octobre après ça dépend
vous savez il ya une stratégie
différente après si j'allais dire ça
parce que la tactique c'est de la
stratégie en réalité nous aurons des
présidents sortants qui sont présentés
au dernier moment françois mitterrand en
mars autant que je me rappelle 88 ou
quelque chose comme ça donc il y avait
attendu le dernier moment
d'autres qui prennent un peu plus
d'avancé pour le faire donc on verra il
ya la primaire de la droite à la rentrée
prochaine ça doit être au mois de
novembre
donc c'est important aussi de voir ce
que font les adversaires
donc parce que là franchement maintenant
dans cette tripartite isation de la
société politique du débat politique
c'est l'essentiel c'est quand même
aujourd'hui devant la droite donc de
rassembler la gauche de rassembler la
gauche
on parle d'une candidature de
d'arnaud montebourg
vous pensez que ce serait
une bonne idée destructeur mois ceci
s'il ya une primaire et carnot se mettre
dans la primaire très bien il l'a déjà
fait une fois voilà ils peuvent refaire
une deuxième
si les candidats sont imprimés toi non
plus les primaires le seul intérêt de la
primaire c'est avoir un seul candidat
après des fois des surprises on peut
faire 5% et le premier ministre
il ya d'autres ambitions aussi qui
semble se préciser je pense à emmanuel
macron ils se préparent elles s'en
cachent même plus vraiment il a dit ce
matin sur france inter
j'ai envie de faire plus pour le pays il
va sortir aussi bientôt de livres il
pourrait être un candidat en 2017 mais
réellement au jeu pour les membres du
parti je ne sais pas je n'imagine pas
cela il pourrait effectivement il est
parti socialiste moi ce que je souhaite
ce qui consacre tout son temps et toute
son énergie à travailler pour faire
réussir ce gouvernement c'est le garçon
intéressant intelligent
oui oui j'espère pour nous pour la
gauche il a des convictions c'est un
homme de gauche je le crois sincèrement
même si il est un peu trop libérale
avant goût sur l'économie pourrait se
lancer dans cette course à la présidence
m aux jo je lui conseille de travailler
en tant que ministre de l'économie dans
ses fonctions ministérielles et voulu
conseillé d'être élu aussi avant je lui
avais proposé
au tout début je vais proposer de venir
alors on dit c'est pour ça que j'ai vu
ressortir que je soutenais enfin que je
proposais j'avais dit si tu cherches une
circonscription en bourgogne il peut y
en avoir une
il m'avait dit que ça n'avait pas
l'année à l'intéressé comprenez que ça
puisse ne pas l'intéressé j'ai pas le
même parcours vous gaver un parcours
totalement dites moi j'ai un parcours
aussi une autre façon salins politis à
18 ans j'ai un parcours météorique moi
je crois que le suffrage universel c'est
quand même ce qui confère la légitimité
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut et élus
mais bon après tout s'il est prêt lui
raymond barre n'était pas élu il a été
premier ministre
on peut on peut avoir on peut avoir une
activité politique
on peut avoir même un cursus politique
sans être élu semble-t-il
oui mais il sort si vous voulez sur
l'air du temps en disant que la partie
sont un peu dépassées est ce que c'est à
ce point de vue ce qu'on disait ils ont
besoin autour du parti socialiste est
pas faux mais c'est vrai qu'il faudrait
dépasser un peu tout ça c'est vrai qu'il
faudrait une nouvelle maison commune
c'est vrai qu'il faut ouvrir les portes
et les fenêtres mais j'ai déjà entendu
ça tellement de fois que vous n'y croyez
pas si mais je me dis qu'il faut
reprendre sans arrêt le métier l'ouvragé
recommencer donc on va le faire pour
autant je crois vraiment que l'onction
excusez moi du suffrage universel c'est
quelque chose d'important très bien
écouter merci beaucoup
stéphanie on va passer la troisième
partie de cette émission avec un manuel
fois valent donc non seulement un peu
empêtré en ce moment dans cette réforme
autour de la loi travail mais également
encore et toujours en première ligne sur
la révision constitutionnelle et la
fameuse déchéance de nationalité
examiné en séance par le sénat la
semaine prochaine
le premier ministre était auditionné ce
matin par la commission des lois du
sénat
il a bien sûr beaucoup étaient
interrogés sur la déchéance de
nationalité et les risques d'apatridie
on écoute manuel valls
l'article 25 du code civil fait aussi
une distinction pour prononcer la
déchéance de la nationalité
entre ceux qui disposent d'une autre
nationalité et ceux qui n'en disposent
pas seuls les premiers pourront faire
l'objet de cette sanction pallier ces
manques de notre droit
c'est le sens de la rédaction de
l'article 2 que le gouvernement propose
je sais c'est normal qu'elle suscite des
interrogations en raison du risque
d'apatridie qui sera en conséquence
encourus et nous sommes d'ailleurs
depuis le début
confronté à cette question le débat sur
cet article
intériste comme on dit le gouvernement
qui avait respecté l'avis du conseil
d'état a fait évoluer son projet de
constitutionnel pour en tenir compte
nous avons fait évoluer avec l'accord du
président de la république pour tenir
compte des débats
je le dis à ceux qui maintenant voudrait
sacralisé la parole du président la
république à l'occasion du 2e congrès
parce que la constitution et notre texte
suprême parce qu'elle a une force
solennel le gouvernement s'est rallié à
une écriture qui ne distinguera aucune
catégorie de français par rapport à une
autre
voilà mickaël szames s de public sénat
nous a rejoint dernière 3 avec cette
question je l'annonçais tout à l'heure
est ce que si vous étiez encore
parlementaires sénateurs vous voteriez
cette révision constitutionnelle eh ben
on va lui poser tout de suite la
question est ce que vous voyez il faut
que je donne une explication avant
d'aller donner de répondre à cette
question et je le ferai
premièrement je n'étais pas très chaud
pour la déchéance de nationalité
j'aurais préféré l'indignité nationale
je le dis mais après tout à partir du
moment où ça a été présenté par le
président de la république que envisagé
par le président de la république devant
le congrès unanime
debout à l'applaudir je me dis que ce
n'est pas rien ce qui m'a le plus
surpris c'est de voir que des gens qui
ne s'était pas préoccupé de ce sujet
avant les attentats et avant la
déclaration du président de la
république n'avait jamais signifié
contesté le fait que la france n'ait
jamais ratifié la convention de 61 et
qu'elle ne l'est que signé mais je me
suis dit c'est quand même étonnant que
ceux qui sont contre la déchéance
pendant tant d'années
il n'est jamais demandé à ce que la
france ratifié la convention de 61 vous
savez la convention de 61 l'actualité
c'est qu'on a beaucoup plus parlé bien
sûr mais elle a été signée avec une
clause qui permettait l'apatridie pour
ce concours il y avait atteinte grave à
l'état donc cette clause elle a été mise
en scène réserve qui a été fait par la
france elle est là depuis 61
elle est pas de la constitution non mais
elle est là puis 61 c'est vrai mais elle
est pas dans la constitution vrai donc
le débat a rejailli mois à partir du
moment où je les dis le présenter à un
public a pris cet engagement moi j'ai
juste souscrit mais j'ai fait une
remarque une deuxième remarque il peut
pas y avoir de différence entre les
français
donc je pense que les binationaux
doivent être sortis de cela et pourquoi
pas parce que il peut pas y avoir d'un
côté des français entièrement à part et
de l'autre de france est apparent il
peut pas y avoir non plus d'apatrides
manuel valls à l'instant il va y avoir
des apatrides
visiblement même moi je suis pour que le
texte lui je le dis ici je suis au sénat
je vous connaissais la mairie one
conseils à donner
avec ses terrasses je trouve que la
formule de manuel valls tout à l'heure
était plutôt joli désacraliser le disque
automates
voilà ça c'est quand même c'est vrai que
ça sera à fronts renversés de voir le
sénat aujourd'hui sacralisé d'une
certaine manière
l'engagement du président de la
république moi je pense que le travail
qui a été fait à l'assemblée nationale
est un beau travail et donc je pense que
cette affaire a assez duré et je pense
que le sénat devrait aujourd'hui validé
la proposition qui est transmise par
l'assemblée nationale sénat a voté
conforme
je vous dis je oui je pense qu'un assez
il y en a assez
alors encore une fois sortir par le haut
oui vote conforme oui je pense qu'il
faudrait à votre confort faudra aller
vite
je pense que les français sont lassés de
ce débat parce que tout le monde sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de symbolique c'est
très important
beaucoup de symbolique derrière ça mais
peu d'efficacité finalement ça n'appelle
que vous lancez à la droite aujourd'hui
monsieur oui je voudrais dire écoutez on
arrête
et sinon si c'est pour répartir pendant
des mois moi je lui tire et opposants de
la république nommé coûtera peut-être
pas il faut retirer ça
voilà droit les sénatoriales vrai ce
cadeau gouvernement aujourd'hui parce
que là le sens des responsabilités et
françois rebsamen c'est à dire que si
jamais on voté conforme aujourd'hui on
ira un congrès à versailles
moi je pense oui je pense que je suis
fais pas le cas il n'y aura pas de
congrès je ne sais pas que ça dépend pas
de moi maintenant je vous ai dit qu'elle
était ma position pour elle présente
aussi on entend bien vous seriez
parlementaire aujourd'hui vous voteriez
conforme le texte est venue de moi oui
moi oui j'avais fait mes remarques avant
je reprocherais la dignité mais
j'expliquais voulait l'union nationale
c'était le serment de versailles comme
dim manuel valls il récolte les
critiques de votre gauche les critiques
de la droite c'est échec sur toute la
ligne
ça n'a pas duré longtemps c'est ce
sentiment d'union nationale et je le
regrette profondément
il ya eu quelqu'un ici un sénateur que
je respecte
ancien premier ministre qui a fait des
déclarations je parle de jean pierre
raffarin que j'ai trouvé tout à fait
estimable qui t'engueulent m à cet
instant oui je le pense
mais la vie politique a repris le débat
politique ou politicien a repris trop
vite le dessus
moi je pense sincèrement que dans la
période qu'on a connu je lui ai même dit
un gouvernement moi vous voyez jusqu'où
jallet un gouvernement d'union nationale
correspondait à l'état d'urgence que sur
le moment pour le moment sur le moment
les nations après après mais personne
n'en veut et personne n'a répondu ni
dans un sens ni dans un autre parti
politique ce sont repartis dans leurs
débats l'affrontement gauche droite a
repris un à un an de la présidentielle
c'est peut-être comme ça que ça se passe
ce mode de scrutin génère cela donc
c'est tout ça qu'il faut revoir à dijon
de dix jours est-ce qu'on vous parle de
ce texte très sincèrement on en a
beaucoup parlé au mois de décembre pour
après les voeux du président puisqu'il
avait évoqué cela dans ses voeux depuis
on m'en parle le plus long moment par le
coup de tactique politicienne entre la
droite et la gauche
est-ce que ça intéresse vraiment les
français vous qui était en prise avec
les fromages
écoutez je vois des dijonnais cds
français tous les jours j'ai rencontre
des associations je rencontre beaucoup
de monde
personne ne m'interpelle en disant faut
aller il faut avancer sur le la
déchéance de nationalité est sur le
retour de la réforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature lors de
l'audition devant la commission des lois
du sénat ce matin le garde des sceaux a
précisé que le texte serait examiné le 6
avril
c'est bien ce texte pour rassurer
notamment les magistrats comme ils sont
inquiets des nouvelles prérogatives
je pense bien je m'en souviens ce qu'a
fait jean jacques urvoas enfin le
nouveau garde des sceaux
oui je pense c'est bien et là vous
pensez qu'il y aura une majorité au jeu
je crois c'est gratuit moi je pense
vraiment quand même que au moment où on
voit des menaces n'ont pas disparu et
tous les doigts d'avoir un esprit de
responsabilité qui doit s'imprimer ici
au sénat également il est là déjà par
essence au sénat on le sait mais il faut
l'ont peut-être que renforcer un peu
alors on va parler d'eux d'autres
dossiers qui sont un peu allégés qui
fâchent au sein du gouvernement
notamment le nucléaire il ya eu cette
cacophonie
ces derniers jours le nucléaire français
compliqué aussi par nos voisins
européens
alors nos centrales serait à bout de
souffle et la promesse de françois
hollande de fermer fessenheim d'ici à
2017 n'est pas certaine je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction de ségolène royal
moi je voudrais quand même dire aux
français qui nous écoutent que fermer un
réacteur où une centrale nucléaire s'est
pas tourné un robinet dans une centrale
nucléaire il ya deux shows deux
conditions pour qu'elle s'arrête
définitivement
d'une part il y a les éléments de sûreté
nucléaire et la deuxième condition ça
c'est moi qui l'aï dans la seconde
condition à ceux qui me demandent de
fermer du jour au lendemain une centrale
nucléaire une centrale nucléaire de
fessenheim
ces deux mille emplois ces deux mille
personnes certes et 2000 salles à
l'engagement numéro 41 de françois
hollande et de fermer ce son sonar cette
promesse va-t-elle être tenue a tenu
jeunes vous donc à la promesse tenue et
si un autre temps et manuel costa
ministre du logement je dis bien du lot
la ministre de l'écologie mme faut que
ça soit fermé en 2016 et ségolène royal
dit on verra mais nos centrales sont en
bonne santé
armentières sincèrement comprend plus
rien de la décision elle est simple elle
a été plus pas l'engagement par
l'engagement qu'a fait le président de
la république
la centrale de fessenheim elle doit
fermer donc après il ya des conditions
de ce que dit ségolène royal est juste
et les conditions de sécurité
on ferme pas ça comme ça du jour au
lendemain ni les parts ou l'engagement
l'engagement est pris de fermer la
centrale de fessenheim luc encore à la
con dieu cette agression oui même si
comme vous le dites ça va prendre du
temps mais oui il va dire avant la fin
du quinquennat
ça va prendre du temps mais peut-être ça
sera 2010 est peut-être ce sera 2018
après il ya les cui mais après il ya les
conditions de sécurité qui sont
primordiales en la matière c'est une des
anciennes les plus anciennes centrales
françaises et donc je pense que
l'engagement doit être respectée ces 900
mégawatts autant que je m'en rappelle
donc il faut faire des efforts mais il
faut faire des efforts sur les ailes que
les économies alternatives au serment
quand la minute du logement je me répète
emmanuelle cosse dit il faut que la
ferme en 2007 ministre du logement
elle est dans son rôle de parent elle
veut dire elle je pense qu'elle veut
dire c'est une jeune ministre il faut
faut lui pardonner mais je pense qu'elle
veut dire que la décision doit être
annoncée officiellement en 2016 au plus
tard j'administre ou alors elle est
sortie de son rôle de ministre est alors
oui mais je pense je veux pas je veux
pas la critique et je veux pas la
critiquer mais c'est pas je crois que
ségolène royal a bien dit les choses
wen mais également ils nous demandent de
fermer fessenheim les suisses portent
plainte contre nous sur une autre
centrale du bugey et le luxembourg s'y
met aussi
et puis l'aurait raison contre tout le
monde et puis pendant ce temps là quand
même les anglais nous propose que vous
n'avez pas d'idée construire une
nouvelle centrale ou dans les autres
pays européens prennent ou qui sont
frontaliers unis disent c'est dangereux
faut tout faire mais on va à d'autres
raisons on va attendre on a nous je
crois une autorité de sûreté nucléaire
qui est de qualité qui travaille dans la
transparence et donc la plus ancienne
c'est fessenheim l'engagement est épris
de la fermer elle sera fermée pour les
restes pour le reste moi je fais
confiance à l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire et de la transparence
après pour pour qu'elle soit fermée 900
mégawatts je pense qu'il faut que
flamanville entrants
en activité c'est une nouvelle
génération on va voir ce qu'elle donne
je paie un procès qui bien sûr c'est
d'ailleurs j'en passe en place et
aujourd'hui qui est lui ministre charge
sans catane de recharge de la réforme de
taille il doute lui aussi le pack qu'on
avait fait avec les verts en 2012
françois hollande un vélib doute de quoi
est il doute que il doute que le ps
puisse fonctionner ah oui bon je sais
pas j'ai mangé pas les éléments
scientifiques pour répondre à une
question
l'anglerre aussi on fait de la politique
le pacte qui avait été mis en 2012 il a
volé en éclats lui aussi non il n'a pas
volé en éclats c'est les verts qu'on
volé en éclats donc n'existe plus les
verts ballon je crois qu'il y en a plein
qui sont partis je dirais pas besoin de
des écologistes oui j'ai co la guerre là
là le parti vert europe ecologie les
verts c'était ça a explosé tout le monde
l'a vu mais le mouvement écologique les
écrit le tube non non les écologistes
servent à une partie importante de la
gauche et je pense que les idées qu'ils
défendent qui se sont imposés bien ce
sont des idées qui sucre est novatrice
pour notre société donc le problème a
été bien évoquer bien traité je crois à
travers la coop 21 maintenant faut
avancer ensemble
si je parle avec lui ça va suffire il ya
aussi le dossier notre dame des landes
oui le ciet notre-dame-des-landes
proposition qui a été faite par le
président de la république satisfait
personne le référendum pourquoi quand on
le met hors logement finalement c'est
quand même le mieux finalement
l'atlantique les autres dit ça ne
passera pas mais non c'est mohamed lésés
sont déjà les camps les gens de
loire-atlantique débarré avance
conditions des collectivités
territoriales
la france a été épinglée par ce qu'on
appelle le conseil de l'europe sur la
réforme des collectivités territoriales
déplore l'absence de consultation avant
cette réforme on se fait donc épinglé
par leur conscience de tout ça oui oui
oui c'est à dire l'absence de
consultation avec les collectivités
locales
oui c'est ça en amont bon je pense que
il y avait des engagements qui avaient
été pris par les uns et par les autres
par nicolas sarkozy ou à hauteur de 10
milliards d'euros par françois hollande
à hauteur de 11 milliards d'euros donc
les engagements ont été pris devant les
français
il faut bien que les collectivités
locales participent à l'effort mais pas
trop voilà on attend on a atteint le
niveau on atteint le niveau là et on va
écouter la réaction du ministre des
collectivités à votre micro tout à
l'heure mais quel genre jean michel
baylet a on me dit que le sonore n'est
pas prêt pardon mutuel
moi si je reviens petit peu sur les
multis vite et si on parle de dijon par
exemple vous aviez dû à l'époque phare
ce qu'on appelle des emprunts toxiques
ait 3 3 ça représente 18 % de l'ensemble
des encours ne l'a pas expliqué aux gens
c'est qu'on emprunte un petit peu
d'argent sur aujourd'hui sur les cours
de bourse pour essayer de récupérer
évidemment pour financer un petit peu la
cour des comptes de l'époque nous
encourager à prendre ce type d'emprunt
oui mais finalement aujourd'hui comment
ça se passe pour vous mais brian je vais
prendre un exemple très simple et un
emprunt qui s'appelle helvétique c'est
assez connu le taux d'intérêt de 0 24%
de 2008 à 2010 8 pendant dix ans il
sécurisé c'est-à-dire que la ville gagne
beaucoup d'argent puisque avec un taux
de 0 24 depuis 2008 jusqu'en 2018 on
gagne de l'argent à partir de 2018
personne ne peut dire quel sera le taux
de cet emprunt ne savez pas si vous
ignorez si vous donc j'ai décidé de
profiter des propositions qui sont
faites chez moi pour profiter de saisir
les propositions qui sont faites par le
gouvernement et d'avoir recours au fonds
de soutien pour sortir de cet emprunt
voilà encore où vous avez connu aussi
des dotations des collectivités
certainement beaucoup d'argent au mois
oui les jambes des gens est durement
frappée oui durement frappé durement
fera comment est ce que l'on fait quand
on a été ministre quand on a été
sénateur on sait qu'on peut peser
souvent sur des décisions d'aujourd'hui
vous n'êtes plus ministre n'est plus
sénateur
non mais je gardais quand même une
capacité je crois de de peser et je vais
rencontrer françois baroin jeu j'ai vu
andré laignel et j'avance des
propositions je pense que si on veut pas
à porter atteinte à l'investissement
public il faut qu'il y est
un effort de l'état il vient de le faire
et 1 milliard qui a été mis en place
pour doter l'état et donc on va vous
entendre sur cette question oui bien sûr
bien sûr on va m'entendre
vous pourriez prendre une part active
dans l'association des maires de france
par exemple est urgent était vice
président de l'association
mais là aujourd'hui puisque rien omis
d'y revenir non mais vous verrez je
prendrais possibilité là non
visagie pas votre nom votre site sur le
moteur c'est fini oui ma vie de
parlementaire a fini de vous savez que
c'est interdit de cumuler donc oui voilà
sauf j'ai eu à venir j'avais jamais vous
savez plaidé pour que l'on puisse avoir
un mandat de sénateur avec un mandat 2
voilà bon c'est plus le cas très bien ça
supposerait une grande réforme de la
constitution que j'avais pu gérer
d'ailleurs que je suis at il suggéré
bon donc c'est puis le cas je suis pas
parlementaire et ancien ministre
je crois que j'ai une voix qui se
sentant dans le domaine des
collectivités locales donc je me ferai
entendre voilà la sociabilité dans le
parti aussi non non je vais beaucoup
donné dans le parti ceci tout ça c'est
une vie que les côtés oui oui je j'ai
d'autres choses à faire mais vous
retrouver quand même notre liberté de
parole mahdaoui je crois
elle a jamais été trop peut-être
quand j'étais au gouvernement par
solidarité je pense que c'est un conseil
à donner à tous les ministres on doit
être solidaire de l'action du
gouvernement il est de tradition en ce
moment par exemple politique d'écrire
est ce qu'on pourra vous lire bientôt je
le pense je le pense c'est pas fini mais
oui vous êtes en train d'écrire alors je
suis en train d'écrire
et on peut vous demander sur quoi
précisément sur sur le sur la vie
politique sur la période sur mes
anecdotes ma modeste expérience des
anecdotes
je vous donne envie de lire le livre en
version vous avez déjà vous avez déjà un
titre non non mais donc des fonctions
futures voulait pas nous dire non plus
lesquels dans quel domaine associatif
non mais vous verrez vous verra on verra
tout ça bon alors une actualité futur
autour de françois rebsamen en tout cas
pas de retour déjà pour que vous m'aviez
à nouveau
et exactement mais tout à l'heure vous
parliez du non cumul c'est vrai que vous
avez beaucoup bataillé pour pouvoir
cumuler à la fois un type de
parlementaires et d'élus locaux
oui voilà justement pour pas que les
élus soient hors sol qu'est ce que vous
constatez aujourd'hui avec votre
expérience de seul mandat de maire de
dijon
mon cul ça va ça va très bien mais parce
que j'ai une histoire personnelle qui
fait que j'ai été président de groupe
que j'ai été ministre et cetera mais
c'est vrai que on peut avoir tendance
quand on est seulement maire d'une ville
ou même d'une grande ville à se sentir
un peu isolé si on n'a pas les réseaux
les relais pour y en a beaucoup et
notamment que j'ai soit isolé comme cela
oui oui mais alors se faire autant
d'appareils comme vous conviant les
associations c'est pour ça que on a
regroupé toutes les associations d'élus
des grandes villes dans une association
unique qui s'appelle france urbaine et
nous nous travaillons ensemble dans
cette association très bien merci
beaucoup
françois rebsamen d'avoir été notre
invité ce soir sur public sénat dans
notre émission 3 par 3 merci michael
très bonne soirée à tous sur notre
antenne
vaud